are you ready we're ready to forget the
further once and for all
[Music]
my brain just been foggy past few years
all I ever wanted was to be a good dad
[Music]
did you ever try and get help I'm just
trying to push through
[Music]
you drive Dalton to college you still
have a few weeks before your students
show up right just an idea to reconnect
I know it's been tough with you too
[Music]
the balance of light and dark is what
we're after you're on the art school I
take it yeah you go here too yes
draw and experience that defines you
when I was 10.
I was in a coma
but I don't even remember being sick
sink deep into your memory
and let's see what life can find
I'm seeing crazy stuff
I think these drawings could be Clues
from my past there's so much you don't
know when I was too scared to tell you
the truth our family has been keeping
secrets they suppressed our memories but
I can still feel something following us
there's only one way to find out
thank you
I feel like I'm getting closer to
something
if something's getting closer to me
when you awaken the Dead the further you
travel the riskier your journey will
become
[Music]